[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro de vibre j'ai la
grande joie d'être en présence de
Monsieur Alain Baraton en son jardin
Alain Baraton bonjour bonjour et très
heureux de vous accueillir ici au milieu
des plantes oui on est bien dans ce
petit écrin de verdure
nous sommes dans un jardin vous
connaissez la passion pour le jardin
j'en ai même fait un métier
vous êtes le jardinier en chef du
domaine national de Trianon et du
grand-part de Versailles et vous êtes
aussi chroniqueur le matin dès l'aube à
l'heure en blanchit la campagne le
samedi et le dimanche sur
7h45 8h tous les week-ends
super avec bonheur
c'est ce qui fait ma grande fierté c'est
cette idée que le jardin enfin est
devenu un loisir vraiment reconnu par
tous sujet un sujet existe-t-il
activités plus écologique que de
jardinet je vous pose la question non
bien sûr et du coup on ne vous lâche
même pas l'été on ne me lave pas l'été
pour mon plus grand plaisir l'occasion
de donner des conseils comme comme
économiser l'eau comment planter des
végétaux et être sûr qu'ils vont
redémarrer donc après la plantation que
faire une pas faire est-il
utile de tondre une pelouse avant de
partir en vacances oui j'essaie de
donner des petits trucs et astuces mais
des des idées que je n'ai pas inventé je
suis inversé depuis une éternité j'ai
beaucoup appris de des anciens ce qui
m'ont précédé et je sais simplement à
mon tour de transmettre leur savoir et
le vôtre votre expérience aussi de vécu
en tant que
quand même oui l'avantage de travailler
comme moi à Versailles c'est qu'on peut
mettre en pratique certaines théories et
vérifier si elle fonctionne ou pas il y
a beaucoup d'idées reçues mais bien
effectivement des petites choses simples
qui les bons de savoir voilà alors on va
en parler à propos de la Rose parce que
la rose le livre de la rose que voici et
votre dernier ouvrage c'est par où c'est
grâce à il y a deux trois mois à peine
c'est tout frais et alors quelle idée
pourquoi un livre sur la rose monsieur
Barathon parce que je me suis rendu
compte que la rose était peut-être le
seul végétal en France à qui l'on se
devait de donner un nom je vais vous
donner un exemple concret vous avez un
balcon vous avez un camélia vous avez
des arbustes et puis vous avez un rosier
et bien que vous avez un rosier vous
vous sentez obligé de donner son nom
vous ne direz pas mon rosier est en
fleur mais mon Pierre de Ronsard est en
fleur et il est vrai que j'ai pensé à la
rose moi qui suis plutôt je dirais
l'amour des arbres j'aime beaucoup la
rose parce que la rose elle elle elle
reflète l'identité d'une personnes parce
que la rose et le symbole de l'amour
parce que la rose et j'allais dire
universelle on offre des roses partout
dans le monde juste un chiffre pour vous
donner le tournis chaque année dans le
monde il est offert 15000 €, 15000 15
milliards d'euros donc
de défaillir c'est que
à Versailles il était de on prétendait
que les dames de la cour au 17e siècle
enivré par les effluves des jardins
s'évanouissaient et que de remarquer ce
précipiter avec des selles pour tenter
de réanimer les malheureuses alors
inutile de défaillir je n'ai pas de sel
la prochaine fois bon dites-moi donc
pour ce livre j'ai l'impression que vous
avez fait quand même beaucoup de
recherches parce que comme moi ce qu'il
est envisagé qu'est-ce que vous êtes dit
d'abord un peu d'histoire d'où viennent
les roses
qui est né avant les hommes sur la
planète tout très tôt les Chinois les
Égyptiens se sont rendus compte de la
facilité qu'il y avait de la modifier de
l'améliorer et de lui donner la couleur
que l'on voulait est-ce que c'est pas ça
aussi qui ont fait ça une telle
notoriété peut-être parce qu'il est vrai
que c'est la rose finalement la module
oui puis la rose on la connaît on la
connaît grimpante on la connaît
tapissante on la connaît rose rouge
blanche ou panaché on la connaît avec
des tiges très impressionnantes ou alors
des épines incroyablement dangereuses la
Rose avait des parfums comme oublié le
parfum là aussi là aussi j'ai remarqué
une chose regardez quand vous avez la
chance d'avoir un jardin et un rosier
vous guettez au printemps l'apparition
du premier bouton et son éclosion il est
possible je dis bien impossible à un
être que je qualifierai de normal de ne
pas approcher son nez d'une rose que
l'on vient de découvrir on a le besoin
de sentir si elles sont bons ou pas
parce que c'est pas le coup à chaque
fois non il y a des fois la rose
alors c'est dû à quoi cette absence de
parfum ou alors ce parfum à quoi est-il
dû ça reflète malheureusement non non
c'est pas mystère pourquoi les fruits
perdent-ils leur goût pourquoi les
fleurs sont tellement bon qu'avant parce
que la plante est capable de percevoir
son environnement un rosier est
parfaitement capable de percevoir son
environnement alors je fais simple en
temps normal le rosier a besoin d'un
insecte pour la pollinisation la
pollinisation c'est permettre à une
fleur qui produit du pollen d'aller
déposer dans le cœur d'une autre fleur
ce pollen or c'est souvent l'insecte qui
va faire cette pollinisation comment
l'accepte cette île qu'il y a une fleur
il le sait à l'odeur et le rosier va
donc diffuser des senteurs pour attirer
d'accord le rose le rosier c'est qu'il
n'y aura pas besoin d'insectes parce
qu'il y aura pas de pollinisation parce
que les cultivé par exemple on sert ou
sous-abris plastique
se fatiguer à produire des senteurs
alors il se débarrasse tout simplement
de la de la complexité de fabriquer des
senteurs pour se contenter de se limiter
à fleurir mais heureusement j'ai compris
un truc mais heureusement les osiristes
d'aujourd'hui ont compris la nécessité
de travailler les fleurs pour avoir du
parfum et ça y est les senteurs
réintègrent les jardins pour mon plus
grand bonheur donc justement il y en a
j'ai lu dans votre livre que 600
nouveaux rosiers tous les ans étaient
créés c'est de la folie c'est à dire
600 nouvelles espèces de roses avec 600
mots je parle de votre livre que j'ai lu
je m'étais dit il serait peut-être utile
à la fin de mon livre de faire un
lexique des variétés de rosiers j'ai
arrêté parce que
j'en étais à la on était déjà à 15000
car c'est de la folie complète mais il
se crée des roses régulièrement des
roses qui vont honorer une personne
disparue un événement un monument un
marin beaucoup de rosiers ont par
exemple des noms de marins du cinéma la
rose
j'adore le jaune je trouve que dans un
jardin le jaune surtout quand il en
mélange avec le bleu donne à relief
incroyable et puis le jaune voyez-vous
c'est la couleur du sable de
l'Atlantique c'est la couleur du soleil
en été c'est pour moi la couleur du
bonheur de la liberté de l'insouciance
ceci étant dit revenons à quelque chose
de moins insouciant parce que vous dites
il existe des contrefaçons ça veut dire
quoi
maintenant être très sérieux vous
expliquer comment on fabrique une rose
un rosieriste va créer une variété
nouvelle en mélangeant les caractères de
de rosier des graines qui donnent
naissance à un nouveau rosier etc et ça
peut durer des années où on va faire des
milliers de semis de pollinisation
jusqu'au moment où on obtient la fleur
que l'on souhaitait avoir quand la fleur
obtenue est en place on va fixer le
rosier c'est-à-dire que là on va le
multiplier de manière à ce qu'il ne
bouge plus et ensuite on va vendre
quelque sorte le le greffon l'idée la
rose a été créée comme un livre un
auteur a écrit un livre et ensuite on
l'imprimait bien on a créé un rosier et
ensuite on le multiplie et le
pépiniériste lui doit reverser au
créateur on dirait des royalties sauf
que certaines roses sont vendues à des
millions d'exemplaires la hausse par
exemple madame Meilhan qui est l'une des
roses les plus vendue au monde a été
vendue je crois 150 millions
d'exemplaires en admettant que un pied
de rosier ne rapporte qu'un euro à son
obtenteur je vous fais pas mal de petits
euros et donc effectivement dans
certains pays et en Asie en évoluer on
va fabriquer des rosiers Baccarat Pierre
de Ronsard
magnifique rosier jaune qui me rappelle
ma jeunesse parce que mon papa aimait la
reine d'Angleterre et le rosier jaune
d'où la présence des Queen Elizabeth
dans son jardin qui est venu vous faire
un petit coucou non
vous accueillir
et donc effectivement les rosiers sont à
l'origine de beaucoup d'argent et
effectivement il y a des contrefacteurs
qui vont fabriquer de vrais roses mais
qui n'ont
sous le nom de rose Maillan
Elizabeth
le droit de propriétaire
qui lui revient voilà le droit d'auteur
alors que ce sont vraiment ou s'en sont
pas c'est bon ce sont des vrais ou pas
ce sont des vrais roses mais par contre
si mais on n'a pas reversé la somme
telle qu'on aurait besoin
j'ai compris alors pourquoi est-ce que
sous le Louis XIV est pas drôle parce
que c'était pas encore la mode parce que
la rose est une fleur qui qui n'obéit
qu'à elle-même Louis XIV ben oui parce
que Louis XIV lui obéissent on a des
aliments d'arbres taillés le rosier bah
il est épineux il fleurit quand il en a
envie et puis surtout n'oubliez pas le
rosier a encore dans la culture romaine
ce côté un peu luxuriant la rose était
un peu c'est le c'est l'amour défendu ce
sont les orgies romaines où l'on tapissé
les chambres à coucher d'une quantité
incroyable de pétales pour pas mettre au
chorus de se vaudre et dedans et donc il
faudra du temps pour que l'on on adopte
l'arrosse en France alors bien sûr
Pierre de Ronsard a déjà écrit le fameux
mignonne
etc
non pas leur place pour des raisons
dans le jardin de 14 il a déjà sa place
dans le jardin de curé car quand la rose
est blanche elle symbolise alors la
pureté de la Vierge Marie et c'est sous
Louis XV que les premiers roses
commencent vraiment à envahir les
jardins les tableaux de fragrandar le
montre bien quand on voit les toilettes
cette jeune femme sur une balançoire le
décor est en hydroser c'est magnifique
mais quand vous parlez d'une je vous
laisse pas souffler quand vous parlez
une vraie rose de jardinier ça veut dire
quoi pour moi la vraie rose de jardinier
c'est la rose qui tient dans une main
qui vous regarde qu'il y a des pétales
un petit peu froissé c'est un mélange de
rose et de pivoine tu sais trop ce qui
sent merveilleusement bien c'est la rose
cette rose qui est là et que vous avez
plus besoin d'elle que elle elle a
besoin de VOUS oui je comprends j'adore
les roses de jardinier et dites-moi
l'histoire de la ville de
L'Haÿ-les-Roses elle est un petit peu
incroyable non parce que quand un homme
a décidé
oui très riche c'est beaucoup beaucoup
d'histoires la rose c'est Monsieur grave
je rappelle je jouais pas écorcher son
nom qui est un homme d'affaires qui se
consacre au rose il crée une roseraie
qui prend si vite une dimension
incroyable que même la ville va changer
de nom pour flatter sur le créateur de
cette rosée c'est un régime c'est un cas
unique je crois en France mais la
roseraie de L'Haÿ-les-Roses et
magnifique et quand on y va en pleine
période de floraison mais quel bonheur
et vous vous recommandez donc celle-ci
et celle du Parc de la Tête de rallye
toutes les rosera en fait parce que
toutes les roseraies méritent d'être
découverte d'être visité et puis les
roseraies tous les jardins en fait tous
les jardins
de tout partout de partout le jardin
c'est un lieu de beauté un lieu de
quiétude c'est un lieu où exact
des gens extraordinaires qui sont et je
ne cesse de vous le dire Véronique
souvenez-vous que jardinier est le plus
noble des métiers et c'est son dans les
jardins que l'on envoie le plus bien sûr
tu m'as fait un petit peu de peine parce
81 vous dites n'avoir jamais reçu de
roses que vous n'a jamais offert de rose
c'est très rare c'est très rare qu'une
femme offre à un homme une rose je le
déplore mais peut-être qu'un jour cela
merci
un grand merci à la marathon on se
régale encore une fois à lire votre
livre tiens on pourrait l'emmener sur la
plage cet été et penser à ses roses à
quel moment arrive la première rose dans
la saison on savait pas parce que
changement climatique oblige il arrive
même que des rosiers maintenant
fleurissent même en hiver mais
logiquement la première rose arrive
quand le printemps enfin nous fait
bonjour et jusqu'à quand alors
logiquement vous avez des rosiers qui
peuvent aller jusqu'au aux premières
gelées mais je connais des rosiers qui
maintenant même en hiver continue de
fleurir la Rose n'a pas fini de nous
étonner
plein de ressources et de et de secrets
que vous nous aidez à découvrir merci
cher
à très vite l'année prochaine pour un
nouveau livre merci à bientôt
[Musique]